kicking off ETS Kardashian ketchup Kris  Jenner it's changed the way we live our  lives the 61 year old momager opened up  to Ellen DeGeneres about the aftermath  of her daughter Kim Kardashian's Paris  robbery we started filming and what was  coming out of that was very therapeutic  for her I think to just explain to us  and walk us through Chris's other  daughter Kendall rocked this Parisian  getup while snapping pics of her friends  during Fashion Week in London  [Music]  back in Los Angeles Kylie flaunted her  curves on the gram someone may come over  I usually cook for them while sister  Courtney made dinner for Will Smith's  son Jaden very handsome yeah baby see  you later I'm ready  Oh Khloe Kardashian and Tristan Thompson  enjoyed some fun in the Sun on their  vacay in Jamaica taking candlelit walks  on the beach and hanging with horses  you are so beautiful just groaning the  beach  you